you've been with me on the morrow he's
gone my side you've never gone you can
we only have 300 subscribers right now
and human hold in our and thank my
subscribers so far all 433 of you to
most people that might not seem like a
lot but to me that sounds like a huge
number 433 people subscribe to my
channel cry any lasted you stand and by
me my question be you got to do one
miracle in your life today what would it
be so basically just like a wish that I
think is unreal biggest miracle you can
think of
get me a million subscribers I made you
a million subscribers amuse you yeah
very cool
you've been with me on
[Music]
[Music]
let's get started
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm about to pick up my best friend
Allison I don't usually need that much
help when I film episodes but when I do
Alice and is always willing to help me
basically I have this really big gift
that I'm pretending to give to a
stranger it's inside of envelope and
there is a letter that goes along with
it so I'm gonna tell her like khaosan
can you read the letter and tell me if
it's good do you think the stranger rule
like it and she's gonna read it and the
more she reads the more she realized
that the gift is a she for her I'm gonna
write the letter while I wait for her so
ya go stand in the shot you put the
flowers here though you're right I mean
okay so I'm gonna give you the gift I'm
gonna give the stranger yeah tell me if
it's good
[Music]
[Music]
stop no
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
whoa my my stranger
[Music]
were you thinking when you saw the law
okay so we were watching it and I was
like oh wow there's a wall on the floor
and we're just talking about ice cream I
was like there's money in the hall and I
knew because he was like suspiciously
like like this and it was like no one
leaves a wallet out like that and but
wait up let me show them what's in it
kind pranks yes you can really keep this
Starbucks gift card and
50:25 seven
we go
[Music]
[Music]
again reaction his reaction
[Music]
that's reaction so far you're the only
reaction
okay
[Music]
okay guys so blonde is standing outside
she thinks that I'm in here buying air
pods for a stranger but I'm actually
buying it for her and I just want to
thank her for helping me today
[Music]
wanna read this tell me if it's good for
the strangers I mean wanna cry
[Music]
I woke up today and just felt like being
kind
should we just hand it to her excuse me
we're just going around giving away
boxes of Oreos could we give you one
okay
kindness rejected
[Music]
hi hello
can I get and then also I would like to
pay for the person behind me hi can I
come back I guess I'll get a brownie
this time and then I'm not same thing
I'd also like to pay for the person
behind me I wanna see their reaction the
person behind me you all come
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now if you don't have a question I just
wanted to give you guys these Starbucks
gift cards we were scared about the
question today I just want to get out do
you question - I just wanted to give you
a Starbucks gift card I'm gonna pay for
in a person or somebody else happy
holidays I appreciate it thank you very
good
so actually don't have a question I just
wanted to give you guys these Starbucks
gift card oh thanks for stopping I do
this project where I got a stranger's
question every week and I thank people
who are willing to stop
yeah how's it going I'm almost at a time
and I'm Co we're near 1 billion kind
acts I know there is something I could
do I just don't know
what it is yeah hi I'm interested in
getting a billboard in San Diego did I
call the right number yeah I do have a
budget and I want it to be in the San
Diego area
[Music]
okay perfect thank you so much hello do
you know how many people would be seeing
it possibly
[Music]
I can see